bfm business stéphane soumier réveille
la planète etc aux bulls en ligne
business
jean marc jancovici est donc avec nous
bonjour jean marchand et merci beaucoup
de venir le voir vous êtes alors pour le
coup ingénieurs votre cabinet la carbone
4 oui il fait quoi exactement c'est à
dire c'est lui conseille aux entreprises
absolument il et il essaye de réfléchir
pour un certain nombre d'entreprises sur
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour elle la
transition énergétique
ces sanctions des carbones l'économie où
sont les risques et les opportunités
qu'est ce qu'on fait en pratique est-ce
qu'on peut évaluer à l'avancé les
chances de succès ou d'échec d'une
action et ses bouchons les marchés ce
qui va démarrer là tout à l'heure à
l'elysée il y aura d'ailleurs un tapis
vert et non pas un tapis rouge 1 dans la
souris c'est un grand barnum où c'est
l'aboutissement d'un combat alors que
vous vous avez commencé il ya quinze ans
par exemple c'est les deux à la fois
c'est à dire que quand le monde
politique s'investit sur un sujet il ya
toujours un côté barnum vous êtes bien
placé pour savoir que dans ce monde là
on ne fait jamais rien sans réfléchir un
tout petit peu aux caméras de télévision
par contre il ya aussi c'est aussi
l'aboutissement d'un processus qui a
commencé il ya longtemps
le monde scientifique et commencer à
regarder d'un peu près ce qu'il en était
il ya maintenant plus d'un demi siècle
est en fait l'effet de serre et quelque
chose non ça plus d'un demi siècle
oui dans les années 50 pour y absolument
et des alertes sur le réchauffement
climatique
oui il ya des intuitions déjà à cette
époque là absolument est en fait l'effet
de serre est quelque chose qui est connu
du monde scientifique depuis deux
siècles
ça fait plus d'un siècle que l'on sait
que si on double le co2 dans
l'atmosphère la température planétaire
c'est l'aide de quatre degrés mais c'est
l'emballement de l'effet de serre alors
qui finalement nous a pris par surprise
d'une certaine manière lorsqu'il ça
dépend qui on appelle nous entre le
grand public voilà voilà dire comme ça
et le grand public en fait il a toujours
beaucoup de mal à comprendre que 4
degrés ce n'est pas une promenade de
santé parce que 4 degrés et nos sens
nous disent nos sens nous disent le 4°
syriens faisaient entre ce matin et cet
après midi la température on va bouger
de plus de 4 degrés ou du cadeau
exceptionnel de plus de 1100 je serais
mort mes enfants seront bord mes petits
enfants seront peut-être mort bon
et en fait on a énormément de mal à
comprendre que c'est une énorme claque
quand on regarde la moyenne n'est pas
quand on regarde la température qui fait
à paris entre juste pour donner une
référence
entre le moment où la terre est passé de
la dernière ère glaciaire qui a culminé
ya vingt mille ans et aujourd'hui la
moyenne ne s'est réchauffé que 2,5
degrés donc 5 degrés c'est absolument
massif au niveau de la moyenne
c'est sans vouloir être je n'en reviens
pas de ce que vous venez de me dire là
jean marc jancovici c'est très peu
connue alors ça c'est un truc mère
glacière et notre période actuelle il ya
cinq degrés d'écart en moyenne
absolument planétaire oui oui
donc c'est incompréhensible bah c'est
surtout et la déglaciation c'est quelque
chose qui a duré cinq mille ans oui on
met on réchauffe la terre le 5° en cinq
mille ans le niveau de l'océan monde 220
m toutes les moyennes latitudes
deviennent cultivables alors qu'avant
elle ressemblait au nord de la sibérie
enfin c'est une transformation c'est un
bouleversement massif donc 5 degrés de
plus en un siècle c'est la guerre
partout - pour voir appeler un chat un
chat
c'est pas du tout une promenade de santé
donc lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique c'est pas juste puisque
bataille de l'eau parce qu'il ya des
terres qui sont aujourd'hui à vienne
inhabitable parce que tu as eu un
problème alimentaire et ce
catastrophisme jean marc jancovici qu'on
n'arrive pas à accepter
alors oui bien sûr parce que il ya des
tas de choses qui sont psychologiquement
très difficile à faire passer dans cette
histoire d'abord il ya l'idée qu'il ya
un revers à la médaille dans le progrès
c'est désagréable commis des tirs
jusqu'à maintenant on dit bon on a un
super marché là dedans on a tout ce
qu'il faut des vêtements à manger des
logements des téléphones chute il ya un
revers à la médaille qui s'appelle que
si on profite de tout ce truc là
peut-être que plus tard on va avoir une
gueule de bois qui nous fera pas plaisir
du tout désagréable c'est à faire donc
on n'a pas envie d'y croire tout à fait
bon et puis voilà donc on a on a
organisé nommé c'était d'une certaine
manière je vous le dis très franchement
nous prend à froid j'adore vous écouter
mais c'est inconcevable
ça nous prend un froid voilà c'est très
désagréable sa regrets plein de trucs en
question et ça rebat les cartes
un point qui est
très comment dire qu'on n'a pas envie
d'entendre bon donc
revenons-en à ce barnum les engagements
qui ne seront pas pris d'ailleurs un il
faut l'unanimité entre je sais même plus
combien de pays j'ai oublié mon pouce
c'est plus que l'onu mais voilà c'est ça
donc il y aura pas d'engagement il y
aura pas 100 milliards d'investissements
sur les années qui viennent ça dépend ce
qu'on appelle un engagement et ça dépend
ce qu'on compte ce qui est sûr c'est que
la mécanique onusienne elle même elle
demande l'unanimité et elle demande la
lune a nié je vais essayer de prendre
une parallèle qui vaut ce qu'il vaut
imaginer 198 copropriétaires mai
d'assembler de copropriété et dans
lequel l'un est propriétaire d'un
placard à balais et l'autre du triplex
au dernier étage et c est chacun dans
l'assemblée va voter avec une bois
quelle que soit la surface de son
appartement
et puis au moment où il rentre dans la
salle ils savent qu'il faut faire
quelque chose contre un problème mais
ils savent pas exactement comment se
décrit le problème vous venez de le dire
4° j'avais pas idée donc en fait dans le
monde politique c'est pareil ils n'ont
pas idée de la description scientifique
précise du problème ils vous avez lu les
rapports scientifiques ils ont pas le
temps donc ils n'ont pas idée du
problème à traiter
ils n'ont pas idée de ce que ça va
coûter vraiment et ils doivent ressortir
de là on s'est tous mis d'accord à
l'unanimité sur qui paye quoi pour un
montant qui est mal évalué à l'avance
des travaux qui sont mal évalués à
l'avance et chacun ayant une voix qui à
votre avis probabilité de succès c'est
combien nul et je veux dire ça ne peut
pas arriver donc la mécanique onusienne
elle ne peut pas en elles-mêmes produire
quelque chose qui va être du descendant
la mécanique onusienne sermon temps
c'est à dire que l'accord arrive au
moment où il ya suffisamment grand
nombre de pays qui pour des raisons
parfaitement égoïste se disent moi j'ai
intérêt à bouger
c'est comme ça que ça va se passer à
commencer par le premier d'entre eux la
chine alors les deux blocs qui ont
l'intérêt égoïste le plus évident à se
bouger c'est l'europe et la chine
je vais commencer par la chine la chine
c'est parce que la pollution des
centrales à charbon est en train de
devenir intolérable pour les élites
urbaines et vous savez quand les élites
urbaines sont dérangés par quelque chose
c'est en général un bon moyen pour que
le pays se bouchent cette information
mais vertigineuse au sens propre
on va fermer 150 usines pour assurer un
ciel bleu à disneyland
ce jeune gars c'est officiel oui alors
la chine en est là aujourd'hui la chine
fait parfois des choses beaucoup plus
courageuse que la france parce que vous
imaginez le ministère de l'intérieur
donnant l'ordre aux préfets d'aller
fermer les 150 usines les plus
polluantes de francs elle est en pleine
crise de surproduction en même temps un
don qu'elle peut fermer ses 150 dollars
c'est la quête du ciel bleu ça donne le
vertige absolue le vertige et puis la
chine il faut bien voir que c'est une
civilisation multimillénaire ça a été
pendant très longtemps la première
puissance économique du monde
tant qu'il y avait pas la révolution
industrielle c'était le premier pib
mondial se disent avait la plus grosse
population mondiale
c'est une pop c'est un peuple qui sait
ce que c'est que la contrainte parce
qu'ils ont une histoire longue
oui c'est un peuple qui sait voir loin
donc à mon avis la chine
ils sont beaucoup moins désespérant que
l'idée qu'on peut en avoir et l'europe
alors alors l'europe c'est une autre
raison qui fait qu'elle a intérêt à se
bouger tout de suite c'est tout
simplement que l'europe
et comme toute la zone ocde en
contraintes sur le pétrole et le gaz dès
maintenant
en fait on n'a pas le temps de discuter
aujourd'hui mais je serais ravi de
revenir sur ce plateau pour en parler la
crise dite financière qu'on a connu en
2009 elle a un déterminant énergétique
qui a commencé en 2005 qui est que le la
production mondiale devrait pétrole
s'est arrêtée de croître en 2005 depuis
2005 ça n'augmente plus ça ralentit le
pib ça a tamponné la montagne de dettes
qu'on avait créé mais fondamentale dire
que la baisse actuelle des prix du
pétrole pour vous ne remet absolument
rien aux causes non l'idée qu'on soit
sur les trois ans qui viennent sur un
pétrole à 50 dollars le baril d'abord je
ne sais pas combien de temps le pétrole
d'arrêter revenais pas refaire dans les
villes parce que pour yann est lui-même
dit que il sait pas ce que sera le prix
du pétrole et il a bien raison de le
tout mais ça ne remet rien en cause non
parce que il n'y a pas de lien entre le
prix et le volume de pétrole si vous
regardez les tout ce que vous avez
appris à l'école sur moi y en a plus
c'est cher et c'est ça marche le pétrole
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
donc ça m'amène et tout va vite un jean
marc jancovici j'en suis désolé je
remercie d'accepter ça les engagements
des entreprises carrefour hier qui nous
dit je vais réduire de 40% les émissions
de co2 à horizon 2020 c'est sérieux ou
c'est de la cosmétique c'est les deux à
la fois
ça dépend sur quel périmètre vous
regardez pas ce que vous avez les
entreprises quand ils vous disent ça
dans les annonces publiques ils vous
disent pas s'ils vont réduire juste les
émissions de leurs camionnettes de
livraison ou l'ensemble des émissions y
compris les émissions de fabrication de
ce qu'ils vendent
je peux vous dire que 40% sur les
émissions de fabrication de ce qu'ils
vendent pas possible d'accord dans ses
processus de vente a eu je pense que si
seulement justement ça dépend de ce
qu'on compte
bon au risque auquel vous pensez qu'en
pour une grande part et sa puissance
d'achat pourrait avoir une contrainte
n'en vendent en iran ivan iv en gérer le
faire mais ou pas ils vont vous avez le
faire volontairement plus exactement par
contre l'essentiel des émissions quand
on va chez carrefour c'est pas le
magasin lui-même
c'est tout ce qui se passe avant et
après c'est la fabrication des produits
c'est la livraison c'est éventuellement
l'utilisation des produits si nous
vendent des produits qu'ils consomment
du pétrole ou du gaz des nos propres
déplacements pour y aller lire d'autres
le déplacement pour y aller tu sais les
émissions du magasin en direct ses
cacahuètes dans l'histoire bon mais
néanmoins ses cacahuètes là elles vont
être mesurable oui alors elles sont tout
à fait le genre ça fait partie de mon
activité de temps en temps de les
mesurer
mais ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est que
tant qu'on ne sait pas sur quel
périmètre porte l'engagement on ne sait
pas quelle est l'ambition de
l'engagement c'est juste ça que je suis
en train de dire vous avez raison après
en ce moment je depuis que moi je suis
dans ce dans cette activité là je
constate qu'il est en train de se passer
un vrai clivage dans le monde des
entreprises tel cas les entreprises qui
commencent vraiment à être très sérieuse
et parfois de manière très inattendue et
je vais vous donner un exemple si je
peux réaliser il vous aura pas échappé
qu'un certain nombre de pétroliers
européens aujourd'hui demandent une
hausse du prix du co2 vous avez vu
passer ça ou pas avec bien sur ses
gardes et c'est même la clé le tout il
va falloir débris au quart d'heure mais
oui dit il s'en fout il vente du gaz et
du pétrole
et il demande à ce que ça coûte plus
cher ils sont tombés sur la tête ou quoi
et ben en fait ils sont pas du tout
tomber sur la tête il se trouve que dans
les émissions de co2 l'énergie la plus
émue si c'est le charbon ce qui est en
train de se passer en ce moment en
europe c'est que les centrales à charbon
se porte bien et les centrales à gaz qui
émettent moins de co2 par kilowattheure
se porte pas bien
la seule manière de renverser l'ordre de
mérite c'est de taxer le co2 puis comme
y en a plus dans le charbon si vous le
mettez un prix suffisamment élevé à un
moment le gaz redeviendra plus
économique que le charbon et repassera
devant absolument
or les pétro ce qu'on appelle les
pétroliers il faut savoir qu'en termes
de production énergétique c'est devenu
plus des gaziers la production
énergétique de total est supérieur en ga
haskell et en pétrole donc le patron de
total est pas fou du tout il se dit si
le prix du co2 monde ça favorise mon gas
et sa des favoris de charbon c'est une
très bonne affaire pour moi donc c'est
un la planète et pour la planète
c'est un exemple et bien sûr
d'engagement d'une entreprise qui n'est
pas feinte parce que ça correspond à son
objectif c'est objectivement son intérêt
alors des entreprises qui ont compris
que objectivement elle avait un truc à
gagner dans une lutte résolue contre le
changement climatique qui en a de plus
en plus et ça paris ou pas paris c'est
quelque chose qui n'a augmenté depuis
copenhague a augmenté dans dix
copenhague est un échec
en tout cas ça augmenter et ça va
continuer à augmenter dans un nombre
croissant d'entreprises parce que y'en a
un nombre croissant qui vont comprendre
qu'ils font partie des gagnants il y
aura des perdants aussi plein perdant il
cela évidemment ils vont continuer à
faire ce qu'ils peuvent pour pas qu'on
s'occupe du problème mais juste parce
qu'il faut conclure c'est la société qui
va nous permettre d'éviter la
catastrophe et pas les responsables
politiques allez vous êtes bien placé
pour savoir que la démocratie est un
système remontant donc la démocratie
s'occupe sérieusement d'un problème
quand il ya un nombre suffisant
d'acteurs qui ont dit qu'ils avaient
envie qu'on s'occupe du problème
donc à un moment il faut faire ce qui
est en train de se faire un moment faut
partir de la base merci beaucoup il est
venu nous voir un ce matin jean marc
jancovici et je cite à nouveau votre
cabinet d'analystes un carbone 4 sur bfm
business selon m